Nevada prisons are short staffed while
correctional officers are getting a
raise in the State's new budget some say
it's not enough that's also well
insurance at a Las Vegas Area Prison are
rising a now investigator Vanessa Murphy
has been uncovering issues within the
prison system and has this update on
Mother's Day at High Desert State Prison
visitation was canceled and there was a
partial lockdown that's because Staffing
was 35 percent less than it's supposed
to be and that's not rare eventually
that stream will snap and eventually
it's going to cause a very serious
incident the prison about a 45-minute
drive north of Las Vegas has a history
of problems as the 8 news now
investigators first reported there is an
investigation into the death of an
inmate in April and according to the
Department of Corrections there have
been at least two recent incidents where
inmates tried to use Shanks against
officers we obtained this email from the
warden sent to staff on May 5th urging
them to be vigilant he points to an
increase in use of force and Defenders
being disobedient to staff directives he
cites reasons for the disruptive
behavior of your like lockdowns Staffing
and food and he refers to Intel relating
to threats of Staff assaults they're
becoming
super aggressive uh with with what's
going on and quite frankly it's it's
hard to it's hard to put all the blame
on them because we're not able to give
the services that are needed we're not
able to facilitate that in a safe way
and it's leading to frustration you know
on both sides of the line Paul lunkowitz
is the head of the Union which
represents nearly 400 correctional
officers he says in order to keep
officers and attract new ones a
significant pay raise is needed and
while the attorney general and Secretary
of State voted in support of a raise
Wednesday morning Governor Joe Lombardo
did not saying he wasn't in favor of
certain aspects of a new contract like
two and a half times pay on holidays and
more personal days and we have the money
to be able to
take that step in the right direction
and I really urge the governor to to do
that Lincoln says it says Laurie's for
an officer now start at forty six
thousand dollars but with the nearly 23
percent paid into the state pension
program the amount drops to about 36 000
and with departments like Metro
Henderson and North Las Vegas paying
more many officers train for a prison
job and leave for a better paying one
you have to pay these public safety
heroes
um enough money to feed their families
and to compare with other public
agencies if they can transfer to Senator
Jeff Stone a republican says he's been
trying to land a meeting with Governor
Lombardo without success he tells us the
raise the union is asking for amounts to
less than two tenths of a percent of the
state budget lundquitz says the union is
asking for a 42 percent raise but would
settle for 32 percent Governor Lombardo
did acknowledge Wednesday that some
prisons are short staffed by 50 percent
as for High Desert State Prison the
department says there are rolling
lockdowns and searches of cells have
helped to recover weapons in recent days
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now Vanessa
reached out to the governor's office a
spokesperson says Governor Lombardo is
committed to giving the two grade pay
increase and 2 dollars in annual
retention incentives to all public
safety employees now you can find more
of the response over at 8newsnow.com